[Musique]
au moyen orient les pâtisseries sont une
fierté les plus connus ici sont les
baklavas mais il en existe une très
grande variété
quand tu prends un un petit boucher qui
est plein de noix avec le sucre là
dedans est une clope dans ta bouche très
délicieux
on a beaucoup de sorties six panneaux
spa chaque sorte de même quand quelqu'un
n'aime pas ce goût là ils prennent
l'autre formé en pâtisserie française
robert kadji s'est découvert une passion
pour les petits délices moyen-orientaux
comme les kinés fait leo à mai et les
mâts moule qui fabrique depuis quarante
le maboul
c'est une réalité qu'on utilise chaque
fois non chez nous au liban il ya 1
semaine de pâques chaque maison il faut
être sur la table un gros plateau plein
de la moule de grandval éthiques
marc boulnois mamolo date et mahmoud au
pistage l'ema moules sont de petits
biscuits faits de base de semoule farci
à mon beurre avec un bon semoule te
donne pas un bon goût plus qu'un bon
goût ont fait la patron mélange avec lui
nous a peut être su que pour donne la
couleur dans le four on le mélange
oui on fait pas ce qu'il a dans si on
veut trouver avec le pistage en prend le
pistage ans le casse des prix morceau on
le mélange un peu de sucre et un peu de
deux doses
on ne mélange très bien
[Musique]
fabriquée traditionnellement à la m on
met la garniture sur un morceau pad pour
en façonner une boule que l'on pressent
ensuite dans un moule en bois
[Musique]
mais pour en produire des milliers par
semaine on a recours à cette machine qui
combine la pâte et la garniture
ne reste plus qu'à rang fournée et
ajouter du sucre glace ce dépistage
ça se noie espace vital une autre
pâtisserie très populaire est constitué
de petites boules de pâte que l'on fait
free le nom c'est un nom un peu
difficile pour tout le monde s'appelle
mohammed ou ahmed le haut d'euros on
peut pas le prononcer c'est pourquoi on
les a baptisés ici boulot miel on les
forme à la main depuis toujours c'est
une pâte
qui vient avec un peu de farine après de
mûres un peu dessus un peu de sel on le
mélange avec de l'eau
[Musique]
heureusement aujourd'hui cet appareil
rend le travail moins fastidieux de
cuisson sont nécessaires pour obtenir
une belle couleur dorée on va tromper
non lumière
ensuite un trempage dans un mélange
chaud de miel et deux roses afin de bien
imprégné la pâte dorée
il ya un mois dans l'année sita mois
dans madame tout le monde
m cette sorte là car il quand il
commence à manger ils vont commencer à
manger ils prennent non remettre
remettre ses juteux c'est plein de miel
là dedans ça donne l'énergie pour le
coup tout le monde puis il y à l'ecn
effet qui s'apparente à un gâteau à la
manière libanaise
il se compose d'une couche de pâte de
semoule sucré et d'une couche de fromage
ak oui au lait de vache écrémé pour
obtenir une couleur uniforme la cuisson
se fait tout doucement sur la flamme ont
des moules en renversant et voilà
températures sont de grands pas puisque
ça vendu température pièce il faudra le
mettre au four à la maison afin de
détendre le fromage une fois réchauffée
on verse du sirop avant de découper et
servir un dessin non un déjeuner les
libanais ont en effet l'habitude de
manger le kiné fait dans un pain le
matin pour bien lancer la journée
si tu manges acné fait ça donne beaucoup
d'énergie
tu penses que tu vas faire durant la
journée car quand tu as d'énergie votre
tête ça promet de bus
salut santé
[Musique]